aquí una de las primeras propiedades
pertenecientes a un oligarca ruso
incautada por francia el propietario de
este yate es el multimillonario ruso
igor sechín cercano a vladimir putin
cuyo nombre figura en la lista de
sancionados por la unión europea pero
quiénes son estos oligarcas todos hacen
parte del círculo íntimo del presidente
ruso personas cabecillas de las más
grandes empresas en el país que suman
fortunas de varios billones de euros
algunos habían comprado bienes
inmobiliarios en francia como en la
costa azul en el sur del país
propiedades que el gobierno quiere
confiscar lo antes posible desde hace
unos días el ministerio de finanzas se
está preparando su estrategia aunque
según este abogado parece ser una larga
y complicada misión de movilidad con
como sabemos las propiedades de
oligarcas no figuraban a su nombre han
sido comunicadas por una compañía
inmobiliaria adquiridas por otra empresa
7 es y esta multitud de empresas
ficticias hace muy difícil la tarea para
el gobierno francés
sin embargo las autoridades pueden
congelar las propiedades para evitar que
se venden pero cuanto más lejos pueden
llegar francia está considerando
incautar los activos de esos oligarcas
en su frontera pero las vías legales
para hacerlo son limitadas el derecho de
poseer bienes inmobiliarios es un
derecho constitucional no puede ser
impugnado legalmente tendrán que abrir
un caso judicial y llevarlo hasta el
final lo que podría demorarse de 5 a 10
años según las estimaciones los
multimillonarios rusos ya perdieron más
de 100 billones de euros en sólo unos
días